well thank you for for the opportunity
to uh
to first uh ex obviously express our
happiness to to confirm uh the release
of nazim and anushay and their safe
arrival in oman and hopefully they will
be on their way
on their way to to to the uk soon
i'm deeply thankful to the to the
governments
of this both the islamic republic of
iran and the united kingdom for for
working so diligently and in good faith
to achieve this happy outcome which
which we welcome uh as a very positive
and as a win for all concerns obviously
uh both
both are have been extremely happy uh
and they're in good shape and they're
looking forward to joining their
families uh at home soon
and mr um
um oman played quite a critical role
behind the scenes in this release can
you tell me a bit more about the
negotiations that helped with today's
release
as i said it helps because
all parties concerned have negotiated in
good faith
and throughout
this process
our humanitarian purpose and commitment
has been at the heart of all our
endeavors and i would i would really
like to wish uh both
nazineen and anusha a surf journey as i
said back home
and
and all the joy of a peaceful reunion
with their families and friends
and when you spoke to nazanin and anusha
how did they seem to you and what did
they say to you
i haven't personally really spoken with
them but i am in constant touch with my
my guys and officials at the airport
and they they assured me that
both of them
were delighted
to be in oman and looking forward
with a very happy heart
of going and joining back with their
families at home and friends
and this has been a long process for
both of those individuals
six years for nazanin and five for
anusha um what has it been like during
that time and those negotiations to be
involved in in such negotiations for
such a long time
well uh
it takes
trust at the end of the day to achieve
progress
and i think that trust and
the strong will by all parties
in all good faith that has produced this
outfit this outcome so i really um i
think
we were able and we were delighted we
have been able to
to bring
all parties
to the table and to agree a deal and
deliver on it
to the letter and to the spirit
of the deed
okay oman's foreign minister his
excellency said bader al-busadi
radcliffe and anusha as they arrived in
oman
on that plane
and greeted them both
before they arrive home
thank you